Колишній канцлер ФРН у стилі кежуал агітує
за свою партію - соціал-демократів. Ґергард Шредер
наче усім своїм виглядом намагається підкреслити:
я - ваш соратник. Утім, людей більше хвилює питання:
чи працюватиме він у раді директорів російського
концерну "Роснефть", близького до Кремля?
Я не відхрещуюся, бо вірю, що економічних та політичних причин ізолювати нашого
найбільшого сусіда, Росію,
не є розумним кроком.
Багато хто різко критикує останні кар'єрні амбіції Шредера.
Але Соціал-демократична партія Німеччини за кілька тижнів до виборів прагне демонструвати
єдність та уникати публічних суперечок.
Тим часом сам Шредер роздає поради.
Якщо вас уже списали з рахунку, то це,
власне, ваш шанс. Найкраще бореться той,  хто бореться
спиною до стіни. Це я знаю з власного досвіду.
Тут зібралися здебільшого прихильники екс-канцлера. Але й вони
розділилися у думках щодо тісних зв’язків Шредера з Росією.
Кожна людина має право заробляти гроші там, де хоче,
чи то Росія чи то США.  Я вважаю, він -
на користь передвиборчій кампанії СДПН.
Я вважаю, це не та посаду, яку гідно обіймати колишньому канцлеру Німеччини.
Тож, наразі незрозміло, чи агітація Шредера
принесе більше користі чи шкоди соціал-демократам
на виборах до Бундестагу. У Німеччині екс-канцлер - суперечлива постать,
адже відомство канцлера змінив на високо оплачувані
посади в російському бізнесі.